And you want him in my blog. I'm pretty lit right now,
but you kind of have to hide this all the time though.
What's up guys, Q and a time. So on Twitter,
Lucas asked me what is the best way to get into data science?
So I'll talk about data science analytics, because that's what I do.
I think the best way to get into data science analytics is what I did actually.
So first what I did is I majored in computer science in university of Waterloo.
And then what I did was I got an internship as a software engineer at LinkedIn.
And then I got a referral from a friend for a Facebook internship as a data
scientist. And then when I got the internship at Facebook, I'm pretty much set.
Once you have that in your resume,
you can pretty much get almost any data science job. And to be honest,
I didn't do any projects related to data science.
I didn't even touch data science until I got that interview.
And when I did that interview, it was very,
very simple because it was for an internship.
So all they asked do was like probability questions and simple SQL question.
But there's one thing that I'm a little bit curious about is what did other
people do because I'm pretty sure I'm just a very,
very lucky human being that I got a referral.
So I want to see what other data scientists majored in because I've met a lot of
different data scientists. And I'm pretty curious.
So let's go on LinkedIn and check that out.
So we got one data scientist here and she went to Harvard
university, CS, Duke university, mathematics and economics.
So data scientists at Uber. So we got Duke university, PhD,
computational neuroscience and neurobiology, Stanford university,
master of science bioengineering. We got Spotify data scientist.
So university of California, Berkeley applied mathematics.
So data scientists at Yelp got MIT, bachelor degree,
electrical engineering and computer science, and then master degree,
electrical engineer and computer science. So I think we get the gist here.
Anything that is a technical, like engineering or math,
that is the best major to get into.
So I think you can't go wrong with computer science,
engineering or math and statistics.
So today I have an offsite with my team and I'm going to log in and you might
see someone that you recognize. So stay tuned
in my blog. I'm pretty lit right now
this all right. Why are you lit, man? You always good.
How's how's different. Brooklyn.
How does it feel to be the most good looking guy on the team?
Jeffrey Che,
how the did I know that? Nothing. Did you fall your neck?
Yeah. I fell down the stairs, hit the stairs multiple times and my neck.
I feel pretty good actually. Yeah.
[inaudible] yeah, this is literally the fifth sample you've taken off again.
Another Holy. No.
Are you looking to buy any beef?
[inaudible] Hey, excuse me. Can we have a refill?
You have to think about Instagram shirt. Is that it looks like a non biker.
So every time I'm on campus, I see someone wearing down. I'm like, Oh.
It's not fine. It's my fan. But then not only Instagram. Yeah.
I'm sure they copied you is your v-neck not deep enough.
You have to put in sunglasses and assume that
you actually have cleavage because of your past what Andre was doing. Monetize.
All right. Let me just read my chlamydia to you. Yeah.
Flip shot. All right, let's go. Knock. You said you're good at everything.
So of course anything. Hi, what are you good at?
Let, let, let, let let's see, Patrick. I bet he's going to get it.
Oh my God. Nope. It's impossible.
I don't think this game is actually fun doing it. No again,
so originally we wanted to do a paintball match,
but then we realized we didn't have enough budget for that.
So we ended up doing this.
No, God
checking his phone. Yeah. He's checking his phone.
Yeah.
My favorite thing about going to off-sites is seeing software engineers and
their political abilities. So not only are they very good engineers,
they are also very good spike ball players.
Oh, we do.
So I basically asked them what is one tip that helped them become the person
they are today. And you said, um,
anyways, so Sanjay, what do you want? What's yours. I got, I got,
yeah. It's better to find out things you don't like to do then.
What things you like to do? Ooh, fascinating. That's true.
Any anecdote for you specifically? I was doing,
I did PR and marketing. Didn't really like it
found a bit of product and liked it. Got it. Okay. Um,
no risk equals reward.
So you don't need to take risks in life.
Like a lot of people who have started their companies, um,
they knew it was going to succeed already. And if you act like a CEO,
they don't just bet their whole company on that random, risky idea.
Everything is planned out and success is off for guaranteed. So that's,
that's the way to do it. Fascinating, very related to the golden path and video.
Don't forget to buy season one of tech lead. It's only for $20, 1995,
20 episodes, four hours, 45 minutes.
Check that on my channel or for the same price you can buy my emerge.
Do you want to give a little bit of input your internship at this untitled large
company? How did it help you grow as a person?
Got to meet some awesome people like tech lead. Who's that?
Who's that he's he sounds irrelevant
dying 1995 right now.
All right. Thanks for watching. Don't forget to like, and subscribe,
and also thank you so much Johnson for supporting this channel. All right.
So I'm going to see you later.
[inaudible]
are you the tech lead.